you salut tout le monde vont à la
perruque je vais pour le moment me
risquer à remettre à remettre le zoom je
pensais ça qui a tout fait bugger
vraiment désolé d'avoir d'avoir raté le
le début le début de la rencontre
je vais récupérer vlad / / / skype une
petite seconde j'ai juste trouvé les
joueurs et on va essayer de pas tout
faire bugger donc pour le moment tout
marche tout marche correctement
y'a pas de problème on va mettre la
partie de maxime
ok donc on aura raté le début de la
première partie on va rappeler vlad et
on va y aller désolé 1 pour toute
attente yo yo yo tu m'entends rouge
tentant mais désolé c'était un petit bug
j'ai préféré régler pour qu'on dit ou
bien année indirects sont possibles on
est en direct cette fois ci c'est bon et
désolé pour tout don d'organes de kevin
une question de temps pourquoi est-ce
que ça commençait pas par les échecs et
960 coup parce que ça a changé cette
année
oye et maintenant ça finit par les
échecs 960
bon d'accord ok bon très intéressante
d'ailleurs pas ce qu'on peut appeler ça
un doux et l'air théorique ils ont
rejoué les lignes qui l'ont employé
pendant le pèlerinage de liszt
c'est là même une excuse à ce que j'ai
pas du tout regardé vers d'encore suis
en train de remettre en place en étant
et en 17 mois très exactement les mêmes
coûts comme la première partie rapide à
tbilissi la première partie de partage
et donc comme ses griffes ue qui a varié
et bons mots je sais pas est ce que les
meilleurs passons structure depuis en
emilio mais ce droit n'est pas très bon
donc je préfère les banques amont pour
être en charge de l'écriture devient
pourrait prendre
m pour great flu que ce soit pour été
reçue pour comprendre où il peut tout
jouer
c'est bon à savoir est ce que tu peux te
décalé un tout petit peu vers la gauche
ou vers là je ne sais pas de quel côté
on décale toit d'un côté je vais dire si
c'est le bon un instant parce qu'en fait
tu t'es pas tout à fait pareil sur sur
ma caméra qu sur la tienne juste un tout
petit peu d'un côté ou de l'autre de
l'autre ouais voilà encore un peu comme
ça encore un petit peu
encore un petit peu tu peu décalé
l'ordinateur aussi continu continu nom
de l'autre côté de notre côté ça veut
dire où en fait ça ta caméra dans le
mauvais sens total dans l'autre sens
mais je suis encore un petit effort à à
regarder toi / / twitch tu vas te voir
toi juste témoin gérer plus à trouver
seul ou c&a temps et je veux ouvrir le
chat est tout excusé nous les personnes
qui attendent le match et tout ça mais
comme le match va durer va durer à peu
près à peu près trois heures trente
on a déjà eu l'expérience avec la ddt de
match on avait des problèmes au tout
début et où on avait ramé pendant des
heures à être à être en ligne à la fin
des heures pendant des heures on coupe
et on revenait donc maintenant on sait
qu'il faut qu'il faut directement coupé
pour pour mieux revenir
on avait donc je vais ouvrir le chat
pour avoir les questions
ah ok donc le chat est ouvert aussi et
je m le chrono
donc la question en train de se passer
pendant pendant sept lalala sur cette
partie est ce que les blancs sont mieux
ou pas nada tu tombes du mauvais côté 1
c'est de l'autre côté il faut tu tournes
surtout que les jets date est
complètement argent là tu es en train de
revenir bien là t'es pas mal là tu es
bien là tu es bien la tv alors ok cool
bon peut-être un peu finalement à leur
revenir à la partie web on peut
finalement venir aux échecs
bon qu'est ce que j'en pense je pense
que le noirmont plus de problème ici en
fait peut-être les noirs noter un peu
moins bien en avoir mais plus maintenant
parce que je pense que le roi être sans
l hérault à boire notre sensible je
pense que n'importe quelle tentative de
gagner grâce à aux structures depuis on
va être impossible à cause du rouble
tu veux dire que je parlais des pions
doublé c'est tu veux dire que ça va
suffire à cause du roi trop faible oui
oui parce que une fois bien ici les
besoins arif d'échanger les dames bien
sûr c'est quelque chose et seulement
beaucoup mais ça m'étonnerait si ça va
être possible
par contre les partis progrès ce panneau
ou je me trompe
christine ça réfléchit pendant longtemps
fait bon je pense qu'ils ont ok c'est
pas grand chose quand même
ou peut-être ce juste égal si h3 d'amour
3 maintenant oui oui donc si l'homme les
pires piette à l'est d'alger quatre
enfants toujours quelque chose qu'on
cavale est à 4 par exemple bien
évidemment des créateurs comme t1 mais
sinon comment est ce qu'on peut
améliorer ça parce que le premier ch 3 2
6 3 dans notre poule donc je pense que
cette partie va être terminée de manière
pacifique et donc un bal oui justement
il est proposé
madame g4 d'objets cas d'échec perpète
oui mais parce qu il va pas jouer dans
le métro à cause d'un médecin comme tu
peux pas gagner avec mon d'intello a
récolté papy tu peux pas bien quand j'ai
montré dans tu veux dire que jordan d un
roi j'ai deux dames âgées qu'adam g iii
d'un médecin qui est maintenant la dame
protège le pion c5 et le roi reste
toujours faible
le problème c'est que justement et que
j'ai dit est en train de se passer
tiens quelle surprise ça ça m'a surpris
mais pourtant je pense pas que les
milieux des sonneries s'est surpris que
gritche aucun temps que j'ai pas compris
que il a ses intentions belliqueuses
mais je suis surpris qu'il joue ce que
je cassais divers comme google ah tiens
là les charges et les dames
ça c'est surprenant attend manger régime
face à moi le roi est faible du coup
c'est un choix très étendue maxime
d'échanger les dames
normalement quand un roi est faible
pouvait plutôt garder les dames sur
l'échiquier l'aurait pu recommencer à a
peut-être sur d'alger cinq échecs les
peurs de roy h
en fait et le pion c6po attaquer les
roues à boire ma long terme
en fait c est ce c'est pas comment dire
c'est pas nécessaire de noter qu
immédiatement par exemple dames 5 et 6 2
6 4
oui on aurait pu juste jouer sur le sur
le roi faible au won parce que parce que
le cavalier sur a4 qui attaquent leurs
pions fabrice sans qu il ne pas trop
bien passé et il attaque il faut plus
grand chose non moi si tu veux j'ai
récemment fait sensation
ok jazz est roi où trois maintenant il
va essayer de transposer son doigt sur
une coalition des trois oui ok en gros
maintenant la seule chose qu'il peut
espérer c'est de créer mais peut-être
aller 7 est quelque chose qu'on voire 3
ou 3,5 fois trois voies de 6,4 voir si
c'est peut-être encore essayé de créer
les grands
mais normalement c'est impossible de
crise inouïe f5 bien joué ok ok c'est
vrai dans les hameaux de pinceau sur le
6 mai avec l'euro en dessinant le roi
blanc peut absolument rien faire quelque
chose que tu peux juste il veut faire
car dieu car que se souvenir
le cavalier sur deux c'est de bouger le
roi faudrait il ne peut plus arriver
parce que les douanes arriveront au
caire y arrive à mettre le carré y en a
eu quatre
et là il doit jouer un coup avec les
noirs
le problème c'est que les bois auront
besoin de bouger aussi
ouais mais regard à 3 à 5 à 4 oui avoir
hausse à 3,5 c est qu il est décidé que
j'allais bosser
ok ok ok c'est plus ou moins sûr que
c'est toujours nul mais moins bon mais
il évident qu'ils essaient de gagner à
tient finalement un pion de plus
incroyable anglade assez incroyable wade
wade 6 ici que vivent actuellement les
complètement gagné trois des six
cavaliers des huit collèges jésuites
faille et c'est bon attends attends
attends par les boues étaient les
gagnants du hockey me semblait
l'évolution et les clairs ce juste ça
dépend ce qu'il va faire mais les voir
l'évolution de la pression de l'école
quand un peu plus dans les finales des
cavaliers en pois de picasso miro bien
sûr toujours gagner ce combat libre
finale des pions sur le principe de
bobigny bien connu au québec marc
ayrault a de sacrés bons moments aux
questions bizarres la fin de la partie
étrange d'ailleurs maxime la jouer
beaucoup plus lentement que d'habitude
vos amis en notre sein d'habitude dans
les cadences de rapid e joue beaucoup
plus vite que cette fois ci parce que
cette fois ci c'est vicieux qui les
briques et le pré sur le panneau mais
quoi
étonnant assez étonnement 1 0 à 5 et 3 5
c'est un mauvais début de partie pour
nous la deûle et français tu as marqué
le premier quiz je peux pas dire que
c'est un très bon du tout pour le
ressortissant russe parce qu'une partie
ce point un jeu mais bon j'aime bien
aussi les parties attendent
il n'a pas répété l'italienne déjà alain
hunault petit nouveau et j'ai comme quoi
week-end n'a pas à répéter cette fois-ci
l'italien que les employés trois fois a
pu laisser il a souvent il a souvent
joué l'italienne en géorgie même tout le
temps contre grille souvenant toutes les
parties la fée l'italienne les chocs à
jouer cette ligne très à la mode avec
des 5 au cinquième élèves jouent essart
et semoy comptera première moi c'est les
lignes les plus à la mode contre ce tour
de coupe de bois et deuxième mois un
voile doit être au courant qu'à mon sens
je réponds juste un le truc si on n'a
pas les caméras c'est que bizarrement
pour une raison inexpliquée quand on a
essayé de mettre les caméras ça fait
absolument de ghetto le tout le stream
en fait c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça
qu'on a pas on n'a pas les caméras sur
le stream mais c'est là peut-être de les
remèdes plus tard pendant la pause mais
sa soeur de jeu furent érigées notre
pote mort d'un fang c'est pas une
casquette ce mythique pas tout à fait ce
kiosque est il est vrai les communistes
mais les chinoises
c'est écrit au service du pro bowl
je vous demande un petit antisanti
renseignements sur sur zoom
donc dans cette partie là qu'est ce qui
se passe pour le moment
en fait partie je peux pas été reçus
mais view à quel point gris chaud que le
jour rapidement
vous voyez ce que je veux dire parce que
c'est hyper compliqué il ya des pièces
emprise de partout et ils peuvent
compliquer - il joue très vite je pense
que celui dire une chose je pense que le
plus probable et moi il est au courant
de ce que c'est pas sûr muscles mais moi
j'ai ri pas vraiment à comprendre je
vois jusque vers ces dames 2 3 c'est pas
bien la cause d'eux possède un deux
trois quatre dom ce 3ème et madame de 3
et les noirs sont bien en vo 2 3 ils
sont cinq à huit accords de bien sûr
c'est beaucoup plus embêtant
un bilan donc que deux terrils et pas au
courant de ce qu il est en train de fuir
je ne sais pas vous mais moi j'aimerais
garder ça pour pour l'instant elle
paraît qu'il ya choc a perdu une pièce
mais ce qui est ainsi qu il a joué très
vite donc ça ça va être une prépa en
fait oui mais c'est qu'on voit
maintenant ça n'aurait pas été ridicule
quand même parce qu'une pièce sur pièce
quand même que pour tokyo ok trouve de
quoi faire webdo faux justice non mais
les noirs one ont certains comme
compensation
mais bien sûr pas suffisant ok ce que
les noirs gulf air c'est maintenant la
tôt sur des ouï djakaridja 4,6 chasser
le cavalier sa pièce pardon c'est
beaucoup trop une pièce est assez simple
à gagner ça avec les blancs non non pas
autant que ça je pense parce qu'il
regarde le structure depuis antoine 13
publie et les structures de noir et
blanc théorie donc c'est pas aussi
simple que ça je pense même bien sûr les
besoins doivent rejoindre a plu aux
enfants
mouais les noirs aux noms certains
compensation après b5 s'opposera cadre à
4 faut trouver quoi faire avec son
cavalier pour à 4 pour chasser le
cavalier attaqué avec poussettes aura
quatre accords et a pas peur suffit à 4
que le mec te face à trois tons pion à 4
soit fixé avec le cavalier attaque sans
arriver à 15,5
que voulez vous trouver quelque chose
comme ça non non j'ai pas peur ils ont
tu penses que les blancs doivent jouer à
4 - enfin ici dans cette position
précise j'ai réfléchi ou trois ça c'est
sûr et puis j'ai réfléchi quoi faut
trois noms à 4 ok il suit et conseille
non enfin il subit conseil il suit les
conseils que j'ai tiré de ce que tu as
dis moi j'ai juste fait fou et trois en
fait pas tué je dirais même pas passé
beaucoup trop étroite aux abdos huîtres
il doit faire un tour d un
et puis bon il améliore sa position
quoique surtout redonner à cavaler se
croit encore enfin c'est sûr que les
boissons gagne à mazout et j'aimerais
vraiment bien pour gagner d'autres trucs
genre à partir de quel niveau a du mal à
gagner ça en partie longue
par contre un mec comme cramique tu
penses que tu gagnes ça non non je pense
pas que je gagne ça contre quelqu'un
comme moi la course
makonda pour un jogging contre green
shoots
non normalement je pense pas qu'ils
jouent comme ça
mouais écoutez je voudrais que vous
remarquez une chose quand même ça fait
deuxième partie que ces grilles choquer
ni aucun mais tu vas donner quoi à
manger avant le juge a promis de
l'hydromel si gagner le match mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé secret de la
maison
parce que 20 c'est vrai qu'il est normal
elle tombe à l'otan après la fois
positive du tournoi je vous raconte pas
qu'est ce qui se passe on nous demande
dans le chat s'il n'y avait pas les
tours sur l'échiquier
s'il n'y a pas de cours sur l'échiquier
a normalement c'est juste qu'il est beau
on ne cale gagnant parce que le pionner
ça va tomber une fois le plus on a cinq
tombes on peut commencer la troisième
partie mais ok je pense que maintenant
je pense que je suis comment donc à vrai
dire
malgré quelques jours cette partie
beaucoup plus rapide que des piqûres de
hockey je pense que je vais pas le
cacher par contre je suis pas un grand
fan de ce couleurs mais pourquoi pas que
mais je pense qu'en fait il veut sur b6
avoir des trucs comme fou prend des 6 et
7 6 8 ans monde et non son style tout
d'abord et puis peut-être des rares
moments que j'ai pris moi ce qu'on a
évoqué son possible ce que je veux quand
les sketches les photos sexy mais est-ce
que gris tout cas le choix parce que tu
fais tu comprends il va faire tout
reprendre à noter vlaeminck lecavalier
mais deux bien placé puisqu'il couvre
des uns et des draps et le fouillent
couvent d2 et d4 au maroc et à voir son
épée une illusion
soit c'est vrai qu'il est noir n'ont pas
été si mal que ça mais maintenant il est
évident qu'ils sont foutus donc un tel
coup kung fu à 5
amen belle preuve parce que tu joues pas
faute page 5 lorsque tu as de bonnes
idées mais ce pas parce que en gros en
phase 5
ça ne manque pas d'aidé au fond tu veux
pas vraiment échanger le foot pour les
gobelets surpoids non mais en fait ce
que maxime a bien fait c'est son
cavalier bézieux il a réussi à le rendre
vraiment utile avec le contrôle de la
colonne des c'était pas mal ce qu'il a
fait maintenant on en a sept partis
cette partie il la joue vraiment bien
fait en fait je suis intrigué concours
pour de comprendre qu'est ce que s'est
passé dans l'ouverture soit quelqu'un
que nous c'est mieux que l'autre soit
quelqu'un oublier si c'est quelqu'un qui
ait oublié c'est du soutien
il a joué très très vite et puis d'un
coup il était fou turc au bout de 14
jours
mais lorsque tu peux sortir ton fouet ci
s'est trompé tu t'es trompé quoi ok là
maintenant aux moines mais il est clair
que ce qu'il veut élever au fond de deux
tours 2-2 et il veut espérer de pouvoir
qui je sais pas attaquer le voit sur la
deuxième sinon sur calais ce cadre il y
avait du conteur joue électorale de m ok
il est dur de quoi en faire
ok je pense que les foutus en fait
presque pas combien mais contrôlé
d'année 4 à l'ère des trois est contrôlé
2-2 contre allée à 4 contre les t4 et
contre les feux mais en fait face à 28
contre le carrier ils fouillent
contrôler toutes les cases en fait on
est toutes les casses bétail sont
contrôlés ceux qui on ne peut pas dire
sur le pion saucette le puits en eaux
semble donc mes chers amis si tu fais un
tour si tu fais le tour 8 17 il va juste
faire tout aux siens on va tout ce que
tu veux
pour eux c'est en gros même tous eu deux
cas valeo ou trois tours eux deux ces
deux hameaux tout ce que tu veux
ok ça que c'est une bonne idée oui ok ça
va pas marcher bien sûr mais aux moines
enfin une tentative de l'activité eau
on peut pas jouer l'agent retour eux
deux sur f 4 auprès f2 tour prend des
deux ça en prend tous en d2 ont fait
tour cessé de après comment comment bon
je voulais faire différemment mais aussi
la jouer comme ça je vais jouer autour
d'eux et tour ses deux enfants
ok ce tour je sens quelques fous rires
aux achats et en fait
ok moi c'est une petite activité calme
quoique peut-être ce n'est qu'une
illusion une autre fois mais un non mais
ça va être assez illusoire parce qu'il
ya tout le temps la tour qui peut
revenir blabla tour c'est cette jamais
quelle heure je tiens le remarquer quand
même que c'est n'est pas souvent que le
match en blitz
après deux parties un ayew déjà deux
comédiens deux bagarres théorique oui
c'est pas souvent on fait donc le match
promet d'être intéressant me direz que
ma parole au quai en empare tout est ok
bien sûr se synchronise c6 avoir voir ce
qu'ils allaient enfin si on avait essayé
de voir qu'est ce que vous en pensez est
ce que on se risque à remettre les
joueurs sur le stream au risque de tout
faire exploser ou pas seulement de chat
ça soit un petit peu attendre d'en
prendre ce risque
bon ça retourne dans la même partie que
dans la première
bondam 5 au fossé 6 d'un v6 ou à jouer
tous les styles motion géant français si
ces suppressions guiraud et les raisons
de répéter cette ligne
ok peut-être zurich morts parlant elle
est un peu mieux oui je sais pas il faut
avoir quand même une sacrée technique
pour pouvoir gagner ça ok il a réussi
une fois mais c'est surtout grâce à
l'aide de dons et d'un autre côté tu as
souvent envie de retourner sur les pas
des endroits où tu as gagné pour comme
un criminel qui retour sur les femmes de
de l'accueil mousse criminal qua non
mais je passe c'est que je veux dire
juste je pense que l'on peut dire
je pense que cinq minutes c'est qu'une
telle 14 ou celio d'être très fort et ce
que je sais c'est facile d'être rues de
bruxelles
et c'est dur d'être fan de fumée donc
moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'ils ont de
telles positions vachement technique où
il faut être très très précis parce que
le vrai football
quoique cette fois ci les mais qu'est ce
que j'ai à dire cette fois ci la me
leroy allèles dams est assez
intelligente parce que tout en avril à
cacher son droit sur les le dos dames où
les mille fois mieux placé que si la
première partie les temps g1 g2 ils
étaient mal mais d'un autre côté il
défend pas le pion à ge de pied de la
paire côté il est précis paulo qui ose
aussi que son raisonnement si tu veux de
jouer ça avec les bois aux usa avec les
bornes
puis peut-être gagner une deuxième
partie est donc comme on dirait donc
mettre le 12 mai mayotte à l'ouverture
comme pourquoi passer les questions
qu'est ce que tu vas faire alors si tu
joues pas sa vraie qui fait que cesse l
issue du match qui voit on nous montrez
moi je doute que les raisons évoquées
sont ses principales quoi c'est qu'on
karama qui m'a dit dans un interview
avec moi il m'a dit qu'il pense que ça
les méthodes de jeu contre garçons jouer
et line jusqu'au l'autre la joues plus
tu vois tu veux dire le l'enfoncer sur
une ligne finalement au bout d'un moment
oui il a appelé ça et là plessage les
méthodes
principal quoique quelque chose comme ça
non mais pourquoi pas 10 secondes ok
j'enlève ma casquette chinoise
c'est bon je montrais pour qui je suis
ce soir tiens-toi se trouve être en
parler
le pion hd sont des faibles ok bien sûr
d'amour 3 normal tout ça ça se fait
automatiquement d'ailleurs le corollaire
5ème au brésil maintenant bien sûr les
faux joffo 5 un truc comme ça
les bords verts vont faire un tour d un
tour des hommes je suppose qu'à valider
un cavalier foot de haut calibre 12
cavaliers 6 et un beau avoir le même
type d'opposition mais sauf que le roi
blanc va être deux fois mieux placé vrai
intéressant et du pense objectivement
que ça siens mais je ne sais pas de quoi
il réfléchit peut-être cette perspective
forfait pura marche parce que je sais
pas de quoi elle réfléchit notamment à
un quelconque on fausse actu photo
dessus
est ce que tu veux ramener troqué
ailleurs la preuve oui oui bien sûr
intolérable de cogner continuer la
partie aller et quand un cheval sur cinq
ans maintenant c'est pas la peine de
réfléchir trop non plus parce que tu
vois faire tourner ça c'est évident
aussi c'est juste qu'il n'y a pas de
meilleure case sur l'échiquier pourrait
donc d'un cavalier doit maintenant pour
pour placer le cavalier sur détroit où
il appartient à nous et non mais cette
partie déjà jusqu'à présent ça me parait
d'être presque une partie parfaite
jusqu'à présent 6 mars y voit la perde
on va voir une suite très intéressante
d'eau dans le match qu est ce qu ils
voient baisser d après tiens il et il
n'a pas pris sur cécile sûrement à cause
de mon sens ce qui a pu accroître son
emprise
mais en fait un jeu demande si son roi
ici vient plaçant ses deux au final ok
mais meilleur que sur le dos
ces deux points mais quand il fait
cavalier à katia d'amin sans arrêt donc
ça je comprends et s'il est sûr c'est de
la tour de f 5 échecs je vois pas
vraiment comment tu progresses avec thé
blanc pour le moment elle j'avoue
j'avais peur de tel scénario quand j'ai
refusé il ya quelques quelques temps
j'avais peur de ça qu'on peut aller
beaucoup mieux alors pourquoi t'es pas
sûr que tu veux jouer le truc avec les
noirs mais concrète que sait pas comment
gagner ça le plus bas j'ai une idée
peut-être wabo deux tiendront ils
étaient sales du coton propos cavaliers
mais par contre tu veut bouffer sur ceci
parce que plus d'un mois sans que chacun
ainsi je fais dames 6 à la dame
nettement moins gardois cette année mais
j'ai un oeil sur as3 retient de nouveau
il vu les sommes de nouveau et le viol
aux dominés dans les faits même
intéressant il veut dire que si l'auteur
se cherche un âge les dames qui toi tu
as des pions doublement moi je détiens
double merci mieux parce que mon droit à
un peu plus actif et c'est un autre côté
positif d'ailleurs que les reconnaisse
un droit sur ces heureux il est quand
même en temps plus haut proche du centre
qui le voit de nos jours je sais que
c'est pas fort souvent quand même dans
les matchs dans les parties du tueur
d'élite ça joue sur de tels petits du
tec sur cavaliers de cette clio 4 pour
contrôler les cases ips inc fcf 6 pardon
dans quoi elle fit est sûrement plus
précis
ok cette fois ci je pense pas qu'il y
aura des acquêts cette fois ci je pense
qu'ils savaient un miroir et 6 dh
je suis même pas sûr que les jeunes sont
là mieux vaut justement non moi qui
justement
ok ok ces îles il veut dire les mêmes
choses
ok ça arrive à jet de m wang de l'auto
2010 - donc accord dont nul non pas mal
pas mal bon à shanghai du coup ça veut
peut-être dire que great food soit il se
rappelait plus de ces notes soit il
violé vérifier alors qu'il y aura ils
ont droit je pense que plus agressive
ça aussi ce petit but qui va faire à 6
arrêts même si kovalev il existe aussi
des cas on peut retrouver dans une
sicile nkam
je sais pas qu'est ce que c'est c'est
game comme moi je sait jamais exactement
ce que c'est non plus mais c'est un truc
avec 6 à 6 et juste j'aime bien parce
que s'appelle pas karo kann s'appelle
juste calme tu vois mais ça s'explique à
jaén malheureusement ok là maintenant il
va falloir être quatre des six petits
rôles ou peut-être à 4 maintenant à
petit roeulx je sais pas quelle ligne va
choisir entre l'ici hockey comme souvent
il choisit les lits les plus agressifs
rire il transfère sa dame / g iii ok là
ce qu'il ferait à 3 ou 3 à 3 foot 7 foot
est roi
t'auras de 8 go avant c'est comme ça je
pense qu'il y avait des milliers de
parties s'étaient pas cette partie là il
ya vu la fameuse partie de wailly contre
bronze en or et bien sûr certaines
d'ailleurs je dois vous dire qu'il ya
aujourd'hui avoir une partie excellente
évolution caudry qui a gagné evans uk
gagner mais la partie festive
ok le roi baudouin a été assortie sur
des quatre quelque chose comme au 20e
cours avec les dames sont ici tient avec
les dalles sur riesch qui pointent
d'autres pièces et sept couples terre la
gaillette nouvelle fantastique le passé
j'ai rarement vu un tel truc tient dans
deux sets en cours d'apparence grotesque
qui a été jouée très récemment à part un
jour jouer ok je vais pas vous cacher
comme secoué mais il est de par astrid
vocation d'apparence ça sert à rien mais
kane & lynch connaît tous le christ je
connais tous que le coccyx mais en fait
je connais même pas le centre du bourg
oui je peux essayer de comprendre
attendez non non je ne sais pas j'aime
regarder ça et comme ça je veux pas vous
mentir je comprends pas le sens du coup
mais ce qu'il en a ok je pense que ça a
été jouée pas guéri mais ce que l'itc ce
genre de ramener la dame ont divergé 4
j'en sais rien quelque chose comme ça
mais je peux que recommander re je
préfére suffisait mais je pas de
répondre qu'est ce que tu aimerais jouer
ici qui vont avec les noirs voilà
j'aurai replacer madame en fait je
récite faire en fait je déteste ses
positions avec les noirs bon ok
maintenant il est clair si quelque chose
comme damage trois cavaliers 84,5 marche
à merveille ce point donc
comme quoi il doit fuir dans le cas des
rues parce qu'après dans ce cadre ne
peut pas vous fait sur quatre soit mais
après dans ce cadre un peu joué cinq ou
six plus très grand dam de ses tours de
7 e de faux sans quoi comme ça
m'étonnerait pas que je suis
si kovalev mais peut-être que l'idée
c'est que sur damas font maintenant je
fais 5 10 h à17 february2010 h
ok j'ai un structure depuis le manche
mais j'ai un pion mais je pense pas
qu'ils puissent faire damas trois ippons
non mesdames moi je fais le centre et
feu dans un f3 gej
puis on prend 12 1 tour 8
ok mais j'aime bien voila voila livré
échec vad
ils et elles ne servent à rien quoi non
mais si c'est les présents chez pourquoi
c'est que le résultat qui va nous dire
de plus les pions c'est de l'arcade 5
tours 8
d'abord pour menacer tous ses singles
had les ltte ont effectué 17 à ok le
jouer pour une compensation à long terme
d'accord ok quelque chose qu'on par
exemple font trois cavaliers 105 élèves
de 4e
voilà ce qui lui offre ainsi que
compensation à long terme
mesdames et messieurs c'est comme les
deux sets face à mort d'oussama clou ça
parce qu'il ya maintenant je vois que
peut-être à long terme les noirs en
angoissant pour compensation mais ce
qu'ils ont appris qu'en l'état cette
gelée compris poste comme quoi le
cavalier peut-être vise à quatre mois
exactement et eau et dans ce cas là ça
me plaît dans ces cas là où moi c'est
une réponse qui qui me convient quand on
avait l'idée de demander si c'était ça
le temps profond dont je connaissais le
coup mais je ne vais pas analyser ça je
connais c'est le coup le court
non mais c'est incroyable quand même
c'est très fin c'est très très faim ce
que veut dire une seule chose y'a pas de
trop de tâches ou même
tient peut-être il aurait pu répéter les
coups mais il montre qu il veut jouer ça
ouais ouais non j'adore le noir
maintenant j'adore avant bon tu vois que
du rock et ça m'étonnerait si le noir
son mieux quand même intéressant il veut
donc si jamais avoir une possibilité de
jouer à quatre bons que gagner et entame
un terrain normal ça c'est bien jean
fiscalité ma du couloir s'être un jour
tu prends de l'espace tu vois dire mois
terrés chez eux ça avec les noirs ou
avec les bourdes avec les noir sans
aucun doute mais tu sais que jamais un
jeu pour l'activité en fait oui mais
quand donc un moment pions ok là
maintenant il doit faire cavaler des
quatre ce que force ou de 4,0 fourchette
ok là maintenant et les îles puis d'un
guillaume hockey normalement
objectivement à paroles et loire sont
own haut risque parce que le fouloir été
rigoureux je pense que les noirs doivent
être peut-être microscopique ma millions
je me crois beaucoup au pc de faire un
truc un tour ses six tours g6 était de
venir en 1 6 mai pour déplacer le roi je
pense que ce que tu en penses torse 5
je pense que tous ceux 5 c'est très
tentant je suis tantôt ici je suis auto
ce sens que parce que c'est très tentant
de mettre la tour sur cinq n'est ce pas
par contre un moment donné il faudra
contrôler la case f5 amri puisque par
exemple les voir vu le frère qui valait
3 maintenant ici faut 4 core i5 web
pourra simplifier le truc est fermé ok
peut-être un nappage me touche ça que
justement à cause de tour 5 oui donc
avec jussiê se prépare tous ces sacs
avec l'idée de transférer la tour sur
jeu 5 ou 1 5 ou un levé à attaquer le
roi est le pion peut-être un vrai levier
maintenance amplifier le truc avec les
dettes cumulées de cinq ans probablement
s'il n'y est pas un peu peut-être un
jour fois à tout prendre trois mois la
calibra est très beau très probable et
moi news
ok faut défier s'intéressant aussi de
mettre son fou sur cinq ans maintenant
et puis il s'est préparé côté reculé de
5 parce que [ __ ] de 5e des tours de 5
le fou au 7 mai plus haut dans les rues
en ligne de mire et oui et si non il
veut au foot
le fou sur cinq où il vise ou le blu le
viol qu'elle vise h2o est vive b2o ce
que cool que lorsque tu vises baie
d'authie visa 3 russie vietnam on pourra
faire des 4 ab tour prend des 4 et
attaquera le pion b2 et il pourra pas
avancer y aura le cavalier c3 en ligne
de mire est 6 e 5 e 5 e tour c'est fou
ce 5 serait très près les éclairer parce
que je suis prête à les deux fous qui
vise le roi donc en fait un peu de
secret à boules pour les points
d'ailleurs de nouveau très chaud comme
est mon ami autant ohlala où est ce que
je suis incroyable il joue assez vite
assez bien pour le moment non ok sauf
deuxième bouquet 22e peut-être 1,79 à
cap théorie crime non pas théorique mais
plutôt 2 de sa cape de mémoire ce cap
nemo rich beem borrigo et mnémonique en
fait c'est ça le thermomètre corps
exposé dans memories c'est sûr c'est pas
correct mais c'est joli ça je les bons
mais maxime c'est pas mal là skiffs avec
son roi de ramener le roi assure neil
dame pour défendre les pions et
l'enlever du danger c'est assez bien
joué j'ai déjà pu s'opposer kevin qui
ont pu quand même offert une petite
conclusion qui ont après vos views les
dernières 5 6 cours des bois noirs et
l'évident kimiyo et les noirs sont mieux
malgré un point de moins parce que les
fous sont terribles et une structure
depuis en mieux mais pas donc année en
train de voir escrocs max va pouvoir
stabiliser sa pause ou donc ça va plus
au pays
d intégrer mais là il peut peut-être
avoir déjà tout reprend détroit puis on
prend d3 et d4 vlad à ce que les
intérêts de calcul est maintenant pour
jouer sur le clouage sans aucun doute il
peut le faire et les très probable que
max mais la preview et moi tu n'as donc
le qu'ils commencent par dans l'es4 donc
tu comprends qu'on prend et la vallée
des saints qui a forcé oui quelques
relais de 5 entre chien fou des francos
des n'importe quel tour prend km et est
le problème c'est comment dire ça me
donnerait si les noirs vont jamais gagné
le pilonnage de décor une fois tu gagnes
le puits h2 est presque sûr qu'un jour
tu auras de deux pions mme passé lié au
congo je vais dire que les positions des
besoins portent un très grave danger
parce que si tout ça se passe
pacifiquement est tranquillement les
noirs sont gagnants stratégique mois par
an
parce que je suppose que il ya tout un
défi mais loue les bois vont être foutu
même si toutes les tours sur notre
changer toi puisque tu auras de pions
pas saigner et yara point dé finale
gagnant tiens regarde qui prépare tour à
sept tours à 5 aussi d'ailleurs
geoffrey j'ai peur que ce trop gauche
trop gourmand je sais bien que c'est
trop quand même trop gourmand date est
le truc marche qui au compteur de fable
normalement requis un peu 4 bien sûr
parce que ce match ok mais n'oublions
pas le fourrage d'eau qui vient que vous
pouvez le pionner le contrôle de casino
et oui mais maxi joue de manière très
active comme souvent ok les besoins sont
complètement foot ue n'ont pas
complètement les meules et blanc sont
foutu ça c'est sûr déjà pignon du moins
le roi
pas top ok et pourquoi pas être foutu
d'ailleurs parce que nos pions beckham a
fourni trois coups pour finalement être
stoppée par le fourrage de rue
est intéressant de le stopper en b6 le
plus en jouant fuji 1 et pourquoi
mais une fois il a échangé les pommes
sur l'île de dames oui cette fois ci il
ira si elles changent les tours il ya
pointe de finale qui ne font plus
gagnant pour les voir ici pour les noirs
si les bons arif de transférer les robes
fr ok mais avec les tours bien sûr ce
foutu pour les grands juste en ce mois
ci qu'est ce qui vous arrive au mieux du
résultat est ce que tu penses qu'il faut
ramener le roi verger 5 h 4 normalement
ça laisse à ce que tu veux faire mais
souvent au même temps qui vous était le
plus haut même si je connais tu te fais
retour ces sept en fait
ok il est la préférée de com à dire
créer une menace d'autour de deux parce
que lorsque tu as que quelques secondes
délai menace d'un coup sont toujours
très dangereuse
une chance tour csa doit gagner comme
signal justement c'est parce qu'elle est
en train de réfléchir en fait
ok il proposa de cette moyen très
possible que se gagne à je ne sais pas
je t'ai jamais trop bien pour de tel
truc c'est pas l'élève de nourrice king
je sens qu roi bouge jeu 4 à gérer puis
à prévoir ce droit ça doit être
gk coeur pour casser comme le foot sur
10 6 et le contrôle la classe b 8 et f4
au même port louis ils contrôlaient les
diagonales et plus en plus dans les
prisons pour tous ok ok ce foutu ou
parce que l'euro 1 au four appartient
pas f5 il doit être sur le caucase ou
encore faire fou 17 peut-être est sûre
j'ai trois fois je crois
ah oui mais mme marois g53 4-way peut en
voir so foot
bon ok je pense que les victoires ben
c'est pas faux demande au chat
qu'est ce que pense le chat hockey au
monde d'artistes que cette fois-ci mec
tient double option qui est au plus bas
et théorique sur la même position que la
bellissime week end en solo très
possiblement cette union européenne
parce que j'ai eus pointe partie avec
ali ses trois colocataires donc dans ce
dossier jouer avec les dés de prendre le
contrôle de la case au qatar avant il
fait ce truc qui est assez risqué
d'aller prendre la paire de fou mais
d'ouvrir les la diagonale blanche ok
d'un côté risques et de l'autre côté je
pense que j'ai vu ça pour info un fait
que ok il est vrai que comme à dire les
pari stratégique son prix d'un côté de
l'autre les roanne loire va être en
quelque sorte affaiblie mais les
branleurs l'ombre leurs propres atouts
et comme quoi plus de ce pass puis
peut-être comme le fouet sur bosses est
peut-être les 15 9 5 est faible
quelquefois qu'intéressant collet de
deux collègues que je suppose ou
peut-être je sais pas peut-être qu'un
livre 4 - cergy à chauffer ce qui est
important aussi c'est qu'une fois le
cavalier sortie de l'alcool et des six
attia intéressants d'autres artistes qui
ont les noirs double double creux ce que
l'important je voulais dire qu'ils ont
une fois le cavalier partie de d2 l'idée
quand il fait froid pour contrer le foot
c'est comme maintenant peut-être fois
juste et les questions soit échange nous
faut soit tube affaibli sa position soit
j'ai pas quoi je sais pas l'évolution de
la position objectif moi je préfère les
banques parce que je préfère toujours
jouer contre l'om mais c'est un peu
pénible ses pions doublé h mais bon pour
le moment c'est ici de les attaquer et
peut-être même à tout le monde pourra
peut-être faire h3 d'ailleurs un moment
donné ailleurs c'est exactement le même
le moins bio est un voyou contre kas
lorsqu'il est perdu ou à paris oui
finalement parce que les paires d'yeux
qui ont exposé à mai mais ok tout ça
c'est que les mots en fait il faut
trouver de bons coups maintenant je sais
pas qu'est ce que je vais faire je
préfère les bons ça c'est sûr ouais je
sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il faut jouer au
foot quand les fins avec l'idée que vous
les 3 6 7 5
ça paraît peut-être un peu artificiel
mais peut-être trouvé qu'un pion isolé
aussi un moment donné j'adore les pions
désolé mr de tête ainsi pour objectif
tout ça il a pris lui même qui veut
ramener le cavalier sur 5 pour essayer
de faire jouer leurs fiefs château il
peut en boîtier pourquoi pas brusquer me
contrer le four je sais qu'en plaçant
sur blessure reçue en attendant et
qu'est ce qui se passe sur tf6 à elle
voit pas demain parce que double attaque
menace d'en prendre quatre dames 3 4 moi
non plus leur bon
ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est un peu
désagréable parce que paraît qu'il va
perdre son pion il ya pas mal de façon
d'obtenir une compensation pour un peu
perdus ou même mais son piano il est
perdu 1 go on peut dire que ce deuil
comme les sécateurs ce type
cette opération a été mauvaise mais
c'est un peu soupçonnons oui c'était un
peu le souk shanaka même ku et charges
sur des 5 et qui donne un teint pour au
noir de matériaux cavaliers au sein
tehran on on soupçonne que c'est moche
on nous propose camaïeu de pour tout
sauver un cache pas lui non plus de
bains à saint chrême joue à rien merci
mon ami je vois pour je vois plus une
vache au jeu toulousain
mais carrieu de était tour des huit
c'était très bon hockey cavaliers de 5
je suppose il veut obtenir une
compensation du type comme food s'en
fout de 5e d'air comme l'e3 ou
d'ailleurs d'escale est souvent pire
même où cavaliers de 59 4% quelque chose
comme ça moi qui je pense que grâce à la
situation précaire du roi noir je pense
que les boutons trouvé ça facile mais
s'ils viennent facilement d'ailleurs
après calais troyes ce point que yoann
vis de cinq mois ci en 1915 - à la
personne ne sait pas mais peut-être sur
cavaliers trophe ardam 3,4 en fait
relève des sols et d'en prendre quatre
effet revenu juste juste moi je pense
pas que les banques sont moins bien
juste il doit décider alors comment
exactement quand le 3e volet simple ce
sens il n'a pas d'autre choix de faire
soit dans sur l'autre si notre groupe de
nouveau mal autant
ok il est pas mal entamée comme quoi il
suit ses habitudes de juin comme en mai
ce parti-là hockey dans des cas très
maintenant il faut décider garder les
dames ou pas parce que sans les dames
même si un peu
et égaliser le nombre des pions oui mais
sans les dames les noirs peuvent être
mieux parce que le fou est plus fort que
le cavalier et avec les dames le
cavalier est signée servez avec les
dames sur l'échiquier donc moi aussi
j'aurais fait d'avoir trois moi aussi je
vais pas changer les dames
pardon pour le moment c'est tendu comme
parti oui oui bien sûr pas mal de choses
sont pas ciblés encore sauf qu'il faut
se rappeler quand même que vous voyez là
beaucoup plus de temps qu'en même temps
on peut pas faire tout reprend 1,7 là et
dans prend b2 non non non les taux vont
être terribles sur le trajet de la
bouffe est bonne et que c'est quoi ça et
d'où il vient de vous donner tous les
plans le coin d'un premier de ils sont
fernand quand même ou des rêves semblent
m6 ok après tout en élevant à menacer
collège le 6 mai pour ça ça me paraît
être un peu trop tortueux ni 2006 pas
mal en fait non 2006 est bien sûr c'est
le cookie n'importe qui aurait floué
dans me2 juste mauvais maintenant à
cause d'un boulot donc il faut jouer
dans mon travail avec l'idée que les
jocistes mais j'ai pas aimé le cadre
mais pas du tout comprendre les mâles au
tamil doit jouer vite mais j'ai pas aimé
du tout ça ok en gros de nouveau je suis
pas optimiste pour cette partie je pense
qu'il va le perdre non mais tu étais si
riche programme était optimiste pour
nous
ok si tu préfères ok vous regardez j'ai
sur d'un progrès cavaliers f5 toujours
qui traînent pénible n'ont manqué
peut-être un jeu dramatise oui mais
c'est mon mothma déjà je préfère le noir
bien sûr pas clos puisque le noir en 3
min couple tient autour des cas c'est
que je voulais proposer assez bien sûr
ces six lots boisés et que le pion sur
bourgoin
les envois pourquoi les champions du
monde de triple ou trois fois champion
du monde oublie et les deux bêtes de
bons instincts te dit tu entres grattant
le mans
médecins sont meilleurs que les siens ne
juge pas champion du monde de blitz moi
même et oui c'est vrai que c'est cette
année mieux que je vais jamais résoudre
mauvais coin ok h3 pratique même même
qu'ils ont avec elle au four des cases
un noir même sur h2o le roi va pas être
tout à fait on ne peut pas faire courir
quatre dames quatre tours des quatre à
cause de damas huit à huit ou dix huit
mois train et on est bien notée en fait
une fois les besoins vont garder la dame
et le cavalier sur l échiquier les noirs
vont jamais et heures am sécurité totale
juste que les rangs de ce parti parce
que c'est une combinaison légendaire de
deux pièces - mais se sentent bien sûr
et bien joué parce que donc les bons aux
mines à cebu 5 pour mettre le coller sur
ce site offrant des quatre cas d'une
idée cédait là je suppose dans 2-3 avec
l'idée de mettre nos cavaliers sur f5 et
surtout huit cavaliers et si ce chèque
est de gagner la qualité doit donc
maintenant il va mutation comme les sacs
de nouveau je suis très optimiste pour
les ressortissants russes tous les pions
noirs sont sur noir du coup l'option des
quatre ils empêchent un peu aux fous de
jouer
sauf que cavaler cinq tours de 5 où il
se tait c'était ok quand les 3,5 gagner
le tour
pour fuir trois jeux secs qu'est ce qui
se passe là de nouveau c'est au petit
nice pour les ressortissants français
voilà ok bah ça n'a pas une bonne gueule
pour les bois parce que après tout rêve
deux tours à 7 ça me tenait et si les
noirs peuvent rien faire maxi version
noire pourra les noirs doivent pouvoir
faire quelque chose ici et genre juste
même tourbe et de à la limitant à elle
mais qu'est ce qu'une menace d'un rêve
de darwin
autour de cela la même ettajdid que vous
approuvez diagnostic
ok ok là il doit être foutu des
territoires à cinq ou six brumes au
récit soit franc marqué c'est un très
mauvais augure bien sûr pourquoi 2 2
pourquoi je pense que qu'est ce que
c'est c'est 2 2 il y avait juste orageux
direct qu'est ce que ça ait fait ça
c'est parce que ces deux bouts non mais
il aurait fait retour âge de direct en
fait la culture en d3 ok ok ok tourache
toi je te vois 3 ou peut-être trop en
france sauf aussi maintenant tourache
sens qu'est ce que c'est mieux je sais
pas qu'est tour à 4 forcé au retour si
swatch 5
mais n'oublions pas les bus h/f simule
mais le roi baudoin ne pas voler est
très près de moi le temps ok il va
perdre ça bien sûr elle va perdre ça de
toute manière même si peut-être
objectivement apparences c'est possible
de savoir aux quatre courageux 83 c'est
le plus probable et moi cette nouvelle
approche cats tiamat et s'ils doivent
qu'à trois cadres peut-être réussir ici
si tu veux une position et gagne 1 que
le terrain c'est très très compliqué ça
qu'il est très moelleux tombe mais
peut-être thunder road 3 1 tour 3 c'est
éric valse des deux ceux des deux c'est
horrible non non non c'est pas terminé
son enquête elle va faire pour trois
mois avec le dr à quatre tous
répertoires auto à 3 aux tirs à trois
points
ok je suppose que c'est nul presque
doigt les frères roy h3 impossible le
post euro à 3 tours 3 donc tour à 4
précision
voilà je crois c'est mieux le dire est
qu'il ajouterait deux mois et les jeux
très très mal cette semaine m incroyable
oui il l'a joué vraiment très très mal
et trop rapide et pas fin du tour ok
donc la russie mène encore environ 2 les
deux voulaient se d2 c'était quand même
assez mystérieux c'est vrai que c'est
parce que j'ai d'autres and go do et le
théorique ses promesses tiens il a
changé depuis la faillite en mai fera de
nouveau en a tellement d'hommes de
cirque qu'est ce que ça fait plus rien
non mais ça y est je donne je dois vous
dire qu'il est la ligne la plus
populaire comptait manoeuvre donc celle
avec four 3 2003 a été mise et les
motards qui bradent non maggie je sais
pas
prague réchou donc quelque part toi à ne
pas travailler ensemble à ce moment là
donc il ya cinq ans je pense
c'était un tour normal games en chine et
il a joué sa partie contre vaut mieux
avoir lieu
et c'est là où il a mis l amour de cette
ligne là parce qu'avant tout le monde
joueurs faut trois dames de deux grandes
boucles
oui oui maintenant atteindre 3,7 ou
toute approche en fait c'est un tabou
qui sillonnent différents coffrets mais
du coup il connaît bien si c'est lui qui
a mis ça la mode
bayrou il trouva canada s'est plaint
mais toi tu es toi tu connais pas bien
la sicilienne où maintenant il est pas
si facile de trouver line que je connais
pas du tout oui même parfois je me
rappelle pas de détresse
ou peut-être parfois je connais pas les
finances mais il ya très peu de lignes
que ce jeu mais vous voilà parce que je
regarde que nous aimons tout ce qui
existe aux étudiants c'est pas
spécialiste par tous ces spécialistes
que dans les lignes que je comprends
bien mais tu regarde toutes les parties
de haut niveau genre à plus où il est
sa foi une partie intégrale dos du
boulot disons que bien sûr il n'ya pas
de parti que je regarde pas ok là
maintenant après +4 que le 4 1 peut déjà
dire que le noirmont aucun problème bien
sûr ça c'est évident si c'est quelqu'un
qui a des problèmes c'est pas les bois
les noirs mais les banques parce que de
toute évidence les noirs une position
excellente
tu peux le jouer comme tu veut
maintenant aboutir au retour celui tout
est bien je préfère les noirs de nouveau
de mes jeux qu'on voit ce qui se passe
avec maxime champion qu'il est il est
dominé dans ce match pour le moment qui
est ce qu'on peut dire après cinq
parties de la cadence 5 minutes puis il
ya peut-être un changement d'un 3 mais
n'occupe que tu es derrière à beaucoup
de changements dans les boules est donc
s'arrête devant là j'ai l'impression
qu'on est un peu dominé dans toutes les
parties ok déjà sûrement pas dans la
deuxième peut-être pas vraiment avant la
dernière mêlée livre est pour l'instant
le joug du haut de grille chou que wes
une bonne impression
non ce que j'aime pas ce qu' il ait
jamais mal autant plus critique
quasiment ok il ya quelques parties où
il était mal autant mais pas pire que
max ryan jackson regarde comment le noir
vous gagnez un pylône 133,92 son nom
ouais parce qu'ils ont tout à fait j'ai
trois que ce fou prend à champ
d'emprunter 3 pas mal non plus et vivre
auditions je suppose fais caca
clément tient mais regarde comment les
blancs veulent le récupérer en valais a
pas que je vais où je veus à quoi
d'autre les gens veulent essayer quelque
chose mais mais je sais pas est ce que
ça peu démodé jetons - prévoir 4 je suis
très bien à diane il est déjà grillé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ces fous de ça
peut te dire c'est pas la peine tout
d'abandonner encore ou qui peut-être
allée boieldieu kovalev ou trois fous
rires 4 ou 5 étoiles ce couple moderne
c'était possible de continuer mais je
suis assez énervé
enfin je comprends pas ce qui se passe
et je ne suis pas énervé je comprends
pas du tout ce qui se passe la droite
joe être ok donc là aussi un duel
théorique un maillot tout ça dans vos
rêves jacques foos trois de cinq
là je suppose ça va plus voir un coup
idiot comme se prend 2,5 donc en
entourant les six peut-être joué ma
proposition que les femmes peut-être
elle va trouver quelque chose d'autre
que tu attends maintenant donc il n'a
pas et il n'a pas décidé de varier
maintenant les maintenant peut-être
varié avec un autre coup ou se base sur
cinq - certains critères de cette veyron
qu'est ce qui te brosses pourquoi pas
d'aller avec 52,7 euros puis on prend
10,5 fut choqué qu'ils rejouent ça en
fait sébastien oui oui ok il est con
quoi il est comme quoi comment dire
triki et laveries la pâte d'amande c'est
parce qu'il a fait ça mais ce que c'est
si bien de faire ça finalement
il pense qu'une fois ils me sont que
voler sur cinq comme quoi il est plus
facile de jouer pour les bonnes peu
importe quoi l'évolution
c'est quoi l'évolution mon objectif
n'est pas c'est pas moi qui en 2008 de
mourir que de tirer les raisons c'est
moi qui a gagné c'est pas moi qui ai
gagné trois fois le titre donc pu tirer
les raisons regarde le cac volley sur
cinq et les bons les pions que les
sharks primes qui ne change pas c'est un
problème aussi une chose je sais c'est
sur les bons vieux le faire tous les ans
ok sauf peut être à même maintenant
peut-être parce que kovalev kata
football turbo cette dame ou trois mois
car les dessins c'est pas sûr que c'est
pas si bien dire cavaliers c6 d'un bush
qui voulait tout cinq de devant et les
noirs sont mauvaises donc il faut donc
faire style que t'as pas compris ce truc
que je tousse un taquin presse que je
dis oui j'ai compris je pense que les
gens pas tous compris mais c'est pas
grave il aime bien quand tu pars dans
tes ligne d'accord sauf que peut-être je
dis la connerie mauves ont cavalé des 55
points ok je me toujours sa position
mais je pense qu'ils étaient passibles
de jeu mieux
ok ok bon il veut il veut dire regarde
ton pions sur ce set et regarde ton père
tu peux échanger le plus ancien pour des
quatre possibles mais rigueur rigueur
ton papier et dix doigts mémento moore
est ce qu'on peut jouer ces 5
bien sûr tu peux jouer ces cinq mois
jour de serre m ok je prends un jeu plus
trois jeux ccj viau et finiens je vais
toujours délicate après oui même je
crois pas vraiment enfants je pense que
c'est parfois un peu chiant je pense que
peut-être les prochaines fois il va plus
réputés ça je parle de moi c'est chiant
car ce point regardons ce qu il contrôle
des huit c'est hyper important ça non
mais après tout c'est que le noir qui
risque si moi je suis tour g8
mais bien sûr il veut le faire mais ok
ça laisse une impression bizarre
tiens tu sais je peux même menacé f3 l'a
d'ailleurs pas tout de suite à cause du
danger qu'ils n'ont aucun droit je suis
tu commences par huawei leuthard oui tu
peux peut-être je dis n'importe quoi
peut-être après tout c'est pas si moi du
tout en fait je sais pas mais le
cavalier sur ces 6 et les terribles que
mes mains ok j'ai trouvé je fais à 5
d'un bo3 je pense veux dire une chose je
pense qu'ils ogryzko décidé de jouer
très pratique d'un peu 3 après à 5 tu
dis oui ok c'est bon je joue tour d'eure
jouets font joujou way deux jours tous
deux 3 je joue tout reste roi je joue je
3g pas mais je vais dire que l'existence
du cavally et ceci sur la planète sur
cet échiquier de pourri le reste de ta
vie quoi moi qui vais je faire rage
c'est 3g 6 3 f 5
les noirs sont nettement moins bien ce
coin là maintenant je sais pas si c'est
l'effet d'augmenter le taux sur h3
peut-être c'est idiot et peut-être un
formatage pas l'un est le roi sur trois
et jouer et faire jouer le 4 ou le droit
d'avoir
il faut bouger les pièces les les
poulains de l'autre côté hockey par
contre les noirs ils ont les jambes bien
sûr de quoi espérer c'est le plus beau
dos et je pense pas que ce soit si grave
la cipa si alarmiste gardes royaux tour
vite déjà c'est pas facile de comprendre
pourquoi fabriquer sur moi parce qu'il
le faut cette fraude et 6 oui mais
est-ce que ça aide vraiment rock et
world food & cie recevoir 3
je vais faire g46 sg ag tout rachat ou
plutôt je 4h quand je sens mais je pense
qui veut faire b 5 à 4 ladd en matière
du nouveau jeu rien compris aux héros et
donc peut-être quelque chose comme ça
quoique et au b52 débloquer de nouveaux
comme gmail y vit dans les bois soumis
comme je sais pas à quel point des
chauffeurs et je pense qu'il faut faire
b 5 à 4 déjà c'est le style dôme axes du
dodo de bouche bée quoi ok ok il est
fidèle aux idées que défend
pourquoi ici pourquoi pas sur ce point
si on n'aura pas trop parce que quand tu
fais des quatre fait avoir à trois noms
oh mais peut-être elle veut jouer brown
et moi pourquoi il ajouté non mais des
atouts reprend bas je pense que c'est
juste une faute
ok le têt il a voulu faire tour des
trois avec le dr breton pour toi mais
oublié à croire et de moitié s'il est
clair que ça a été fait
y'a pas d'autres explications
ok les besoins le terme même si les
boissons un peu mieux mais bien sûr une
fois les tournois sont activé les bornes
pire diouf peut-être tous les avantages
tout à l'heure la grosse partie de l'est
entre rock et maka je pense que
peut-être elle va essayer de commander
au groupe de faire mieux les oublis
sport à tiens ça c'est intéressant je
compris ce qu'il veut il veut changer le
plein d pour le pineau 6 pour une criée
les faux blessures cinq mois il veut
replacer son père un univers bien à
crier sur les cases f5
une fois les cavaliers laisser les clés
pour d'autres trucs nos trois trucs pour
nous faut sur des six qui voudraient
pose pour le plus on a six qui bordent
les pelouses et pour les droits je sais
qu'il va devenir faible très intéressant
parfois grichka très fréquemment
ok moi d'accord les 2 4 et bien sûr à
tiers des 5 par contre ça c'était très
très bien ça enfin un jeu de extra extra
extra classe il a vu si vite
j'adore j'adore de comment dire j'adore
admiré comme quelqu'un joue de manière
aussi incapable je suis capable sur deux
jeux à 2,5 mais pas aussi vite
ok donc maintenant qu'est-ce que le plus
précis si carole et f5 de régis à leurs
questions mais a fait cavalier b5 aussi
peut-être quolibets 513 en a beaucoup
moins mais le gagnant pions comme ça
donc au moins se pratique et n'oublions
pas d'ailleurs cette fois ci une autre
fois il est pas mal de temps le nom mais
on souffre vous souffrez
nous on souffre mais peut-être pas
présentables je peux vous dire enfin que
en tant que ce qui doit devenir les
masses de gagner en pièces donc moi je
serais obligé maintenant
et puis bien sûr continuer de spéculer
sur l'oie avec les d4 mais je suis pas
sûr qu'il va le faire mais ça dépend
qu'est ce qu'il pense de la finale est
prêt qu'à valider si ce détour de six
touristes de 6 est-ce qu'il pense que
c'est plutôt gagne à l'autre le taux nul
parce que les chevalets cool bien sûr
sans aucun doute son droit est meilleure
mais c'est que son doublé avec le nom
n'a pas le temps de faire des trois pour
mieux on n'a pas le temps de faire vos
toiles et simon les bois menace tour p4
donc les noirs sont obligés de chedjou
mais le pen c'est je crois ce qui se
passe après re 4 à 2,4 à c4 a peut-être
ce juste abandon mais maintenant elle
doit changer la pose du roi les poses de
de la taupe est un territoire avec
l'aider à tour à tour de cadres et mais
en fait je crois il a échangé la
deuxième paire de tours il aurait pu
rentrer avec le plus de tours sur
l'échiquier dans cette finale non
monsieur on est très faible
non ok mais les faits mais les biens
maintenant maintenant est ce qu'il va
pouvoir résister tour des quatre je vois
pas comment je vois pas ça me paraît
d'autant plus ou moins la fin ok tour de
trois tours à 4 donc tourbe cad tient et
la bonne chose d'ailleurs deux fois déjà
elle est abondante et plus tôt
un peu plus tôt que quelqu'un d'autre
ferait par exemple plus quoi c'est pas
si mal que ça va devenir plus facile
avec la charge
le changement de la cabane tu sais qu'à
m'a dit le sélectionneur de l'équipe
d'algérie de rugby j'en ai plein les
couilles de perdre 6 6 il a dit ça qu il
a dit je peux plus perdre je suis en
guerre et la vidéo en fait il dit que ça
fait vingt matches qu'il est
sélectionneur de l'équipe
tu sais combien de défaites bon vin
c'est pour ça que ken hawk et regardez
maintenant je pense que j'ai quoi dire
que pour cette pression je pense que ces
excès mois le type d'opposition où le
fou et très moelleux procès sur hbo deux
parce que les lois vont mettre le caveau
hockey local est déjà visible une fois
chassés de jeu 4 il va viser sans devoir
aller sur scène pour d'où il va viser 2
3 et les bains va se déplacer sur bois
6e puis le noir vont [ __ ] à 5 à 4 elle
cette position elle est très très très
dangereuse pour les
j'en ai marre j'en peu près très
dangereuse parce que ici même pour ne
pas se retrouver avec des problèmes tout
de suite il faut être très précis b4 je
sais pas écoutez je sais pas peut-être
dans m6 2006 que va lire trois cas valeo
4 je peux rien je sais pas peut-être
dont je peux te dire je ne sais pas d'un
v6 à parce que j'ai pas vu ok cavale et
f2 relève d'autres 2006 comme les trois
mâts ce message peut pas
peut-être je peux jouer comme réussis
sur 6 pratique d'ailleurs je suis sûr
que volet de ce n'est pas mal aussi
parce que je marque avant les bus tice
oui je pense que me cavalière de sept
bonds milanais ce sera
pardon d'un v6 qui croient pas je sais
pas si pas c'est bien pour pouvoir
calculer maintenant d'un v6 hockey qui
menace dans le cadre du précédent baisse
de régime est juste mauvais donc les
besoins
comme quoi obligé de jouer à trois et
après trois escrocs yacco réussissent ce
cinq de ses co volé à quatre voix tu
vois c'est pas si facile de calculer
quoi faire attention cavalli g4 si tu
ferais sans prise sur quels étaient ces
différents projets 4 oui tu perds pas
comme ça mais peut-être que tu perds ton
avantage parce que c'est sûr qu'il noie
son mieux oui à priori en france et 4 en
fait aux rockets et les 17 et 3
peut-être un fait social et des a320 à
a3 est ce que relève deux marches à 3
que vos lèvres deux rois f27 kara lieu
si ça prend on réussissait pas même plus
de gueule
mon corps lire dommage pas donc à trois
qui réussissent et 6 e 5 comme les seins
quand le 6 et 6 2 4
tout était ok quand même cadre les noirs
sont très bien mais je ne sais pas est
ce que nous sommes mieux
ok mais il doit jouer à trois mais je
sais pas qui
à l'exemple de calcul et je pense même à
5 ici au parlement les blancs menace
juste rien peut-être pourquoi pas
d'heure pour rendre plus justes arabe
est en fait d'ailleurs cessé les voiles
doivent qui doivent comprendre qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire après à ses impôts ce
que c'est un pion un pion comme à dire
qu' une fois de plus on a cinq tombes
toutes les positions ses collègues mais
si phase 1 qui a réussi à faire ab
aprilia de ceccatty temps il ya tout qui
tombe lorient tout que tout va bientôt
sur eux on va tomber après les tortures
rares loi
j'envoie tombeur non mesure sébastien
est ce que je colle eduardo food et
quatre dans deux catégories de quake
wars ont redit plus doucement
est ce que les noirs purgeurs voile
cavaliere doit rêve de fou de 4 dans des
quatre cavaliers gouache et marne
n'était 3,3 tandis qu'à 3 des 4 vallées
bourbourg et se sent que c'est quoi
moi j'ai vu je vais essayer de montrer
pour les auditeurs comme on joue ce jeu
presque pour les auditeurs ça va être
marrant parce que la ligne les
romantiques wap attend caïds et trois
rois ou trois à temps je vous ai regardé
qu'est-ce que tu montres et qu'areva les
vivres au lieu de 1,5
les bourreaux f2 food et quatre dans des
quatre cavaliers de travaux à croître de
4 3 des 4 cavaliers boudeuse est tombé
et c'est sans risque il faut pas s'en
cacher et tu sois avec son cavalier soit
parce que ces quatre soit par de trois
jolis jeux les rues mais je ne suis pas
sûr que c'est si bien qu'il s'agit un
truc que je veux plus que ok il a fait
un simple plus pratique le pratiquer ta
proposition
non non ce qui est bien avec 1,5 c'est
que tu laisses l'autre s'en sortir en
fait eu justement parce que comment dire
les noirs pour l'instant le risque réel
de tous les besoins doivent
comprendre comment savourer ce que
paraît de s'écrouler
mais en fait pourquoi il ya donc
maintenant vous voyez ce que j'étais en
train de dire comme je dis que l'oph ou
sur bordeaux est toujours mois le procès
dans ce pression vous voyez nous on voit
jeu parce que le faux sur bodoï qu'on me
les bouées qui parle aux cavaliers ces
trois ils contrôlent pas des cadres est
un plus et les dans l'air une fois les
lois retouche le pion ben oui oui donc
c'est pour ça qu'il est si mauvais que
ça
en fait le fou de ce type de pressions
de la part tient dans les classes aux
trois ou quatre halls des clac et f2
d'accord qu'est ce que tu penses que
green shoots domine autant parce qu'ils
jouent bien où est ce que tu penses que
max jouer assez mal ce soir
ou les deux non il est trop tôt d'en
parler
il est trop tôt d'en parler je veux pas
me prononcer encore sur ce sujet je
pense que de richibouctou bien ok de
toute évidence ne le doit pas jouer
retrouve bien il est clair que le
secours à présent mais je ne sais pas à
quel point c'est eu un truc où les
auteurs donc c'est il est trop tôt de
jeu qu'elle a fait cavalia 2 il défend
des quatre éléphants des quatre hockey
le pape y avait au guildo mon secours
donc moi n'a pas eu ce coup mais
peut-être ça veut dire quoi que les bons
cavaliers à 4 et le joue quoi travaille
à kaspar est très pénible
tu menaces le four b2 et c on va pas non
parce que tout s'écroule oui comme on a
promis mme bonds +4 quelque chose ça
commence à faire cher vad
ok disons que pour l'instant ce qu'il
craint de voir ses s'est fait comme
ailleurs c'est comme quoi blitzkrieg
mais non ils ont toutes plus quoi les
stratégies de blitzkrieg dame dans un
match de blida brûle c'est là qu'ils
nous aient glissé des résines à 2.0 pour
l'instant c'est pire is you know we may
ok je peux vous dire les français qui
ont ils un vrai s'accorde aux cadences
oui moi je suis optimiste mais pas
autant que ce à quoi je sais qu est ce
que peut nous arriver plus tard avant
goût - ericsson donc mais à vrai dire je
suis quand même surpris par le fait qu'
au max continue d'employer cette ligne
pas parce que les mauvaises peut-être je
ne sais pas mais elle est quand même
plus sécure pour les bois manque je
comprends pas trop en fait parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'il est mal avec les
blancs et avec les noirs à la sortie d
ouverture
mais tu sais en fait quand tu es mal
avec les noirs étaient très souvent mal
avec les bois parce que tant peu plus
bas parce que tu allais pression parce
que tu as autant l'horreur de la partie
suivante avec les noirs qui autour ou
qui fait n'importe quoi avec les banques
toi donc ça arrive ça aussi mais pour
quoi il retourne sur les sur les pas du
crime parce qu'il a ça j'arrive pas à
comprendre ce que les obtenions me
paraît pas un terrain la pose de rêve on
est peut-être il s'est dit qu'il sait
des caveaux les sécateurs de n'importe
quoi ce que d'ailleurs nous a mahdia les
toits ou avant c'est étonnant en fait ok
maintenant si un jour qu'en valais un
saint
valeo possède le problème c'est que le
noie on intermédiaire avec fo aux 5 2 e
dan et que après tout point vert et noir
prendre sur bosses est oui donc c'est là
où je me suis trompé quand je calculais
cette ligne bordeaux 3
oui j'ai lu tous vos cette dame noire
mais j'ai pas vu l'intermédiaire fou et
s'inscrit ce que j'avais pour un papier
de moscou donc qu'est ce qu'il va faire
si mon hockey il est décidé d'obtenir sa
de notre manière
donc pourquoi ok je peux pas jouer tout
ça ok je tiens ça de notre mieux mais
peut-être sonné qu'il est réputé sur les
répétitions de les parties que ce moment
je me répète le de leurs récits pour le
nom c'est la répétition
d'ailleurs il y avait déjà eu il ya gros
chat qui nous dit la pression il faut la
boire pas la subir
tu comprends ce jeu de vos impôts je
suis d'accord avec toi tu comprend 1 c
avant c'était ma solution toute ma vie
va basculer pour moi même ok mais
pourquoi il répète ça mais est ce que
est ce qu ils purent au hockey avoir son
problème qui a pas un seul tournoi
aurait pu être placés sur la colombie
oui c'est facile a réussi à mettre une
cette fois ci aux moines là pour deux
tours se retrouver sur deux sets mais
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya les
noix son sens et bien ça me connaît déjà
les besoins pour bouffer sur ce rapport
en gros je vais dire que les noix les
boissons secure l'émouvoir je sais pas
s'il a peut-être fait retour g8 ici wac
est aujourd'hui dans mon jeu et ma foi
si cela marche pas quand même d'un mois
je trouve quand même sans aucun doute
rock est un pion de pelouse la mahatma
guy gambu 3com a vraiment le plus beau
mec ça te dit de répéter mais tête d'un
des 3 es fou prend des 4 à la fin
oui mais il n'a pas décédée il est
décidé de ne pas répéter mon rap l'étagé
refn badiane
je pense que les de nouveau très mal
dans cette année très très mal
est-ce que kovalev cette grippe ainsi
que ça donne tout de suite mais cet
amour et cette hausse suit trois jeux
c'est dans le cas d'un abandon
ça promet +5 si je me trompe pas non
mais j'en peux plus vlad je te comprend
les enseignes mal si je vois tout de
suite
ouais je vois pas comment c'est un peu
risqué tout ça ok bien sûr tu peux c'est
pas les pratiques de faire ce geste
enfin non je comprends mais ce
jusqu'après sg j'ai un pion de plus si
je me trompe pas et d'un tel poids dit
asian and home
ah oui et à la fois d'après et france je
sens qu'il n'y a pas d'âme dottore
autour de chez parce que la dame
contrôle bien qu'ils viennent bon tout
ça ce qui aurait pu avoir de ta meuf
détour d un mais ça marche pas avec le
match du couloir
parce que la dame contrôle c'est beau
c'est un espoir non mais j'en ai marre y
apprendrez beaucoup oui voilà tour hebdo
autour d'un parce que la dame sur
jonathan ya peut-être un truc parce
qu'il réfléchit depuis un moment là
quand même quand cavaliers f7 bon
tourcoing fc est forcé tour ses 8,3 g7
forcé dame g4 ou g5 forcé oui c'est un
point de plus et tout continue
d'attaquer le roi je pense que il
commence à peler et les chéquards cheikh
cela trois fois et puis le fait que
j'espère pas les regards sont imposés
ségo c'est simple tout au plus et
rigueur ne voit quoi
ok il est pas du tout obligé à faire ça
bien sûr ah oui il a fait ça
non mais ok ça commence à faire too much
bon ok il faut prendre le pion g5 faire
tourner ici c'est sauver sauver une
partie non non je suis sûr je vis trois
jeux vite balle je suis sûr je sai baba
cissé puis je trouve à je te sors la
touche témoin non mais justin je sais
pas mais je suis très surpris vlad par
le parc par le match pour le moment moi
aussi parce que très possible et moi les
deux joueurs aussi leur mais peut-être
canevet les pae pachot enfin je sais pas
enfin c'est très étrange est au maximum
et mieux une boulette qui au gris chaud
moi j'ai pas de réponse je sais pas là
on espère non feinte patois mais nous
oui mais moi j'ai aucune idée
qui mieux pourquoi pas possible si c'est
le cas dans ce cas là il a comment dire
il doit quand même amélioré son square
avant parce que si c'est moins 5
même si ce même site et mieux un boulet
tu vois pas complètement mort le khessal
nouvelle gueule bien sûr ok bien sûr ce
doit être complètement moi mais brock et
ce double x tu vois non parce que si
elles investissent sur des cinq déjà
qu'est ce que le noir jouent après tous
dame de cette eau non pardon qu'est ce
que le gars joue après tout ça ok je
comprends pas à quoi il faisait 4 ans
que je conduis je comprends le coup je
lis mais pourquoi pas tout ça et puis je
pensais en fait que d'amd s'inquiétait
pas besoin d'un peu de tours c'est un
mois même temps aucune idée c'est quoi
les premiers signes de fatigue ou quoi
ce que jk foot dames f3 et j'y crois de
nouveau quoi owens 4 2
vous savez on sait juste pour ces huit
m'attend et je vois juste pas comment
vous pouvez par et ça parce que surtout
reif 8 y'avait dame g7 mater si la dame
n'est protégé mesdames preuve cette
actuelle mais il propose nul
ah non il propose pas nul parce que dans
un mois je crois pas d'amour c'est à
cause de pirouettes moto mais non ils
proposent points nul ok comme ça il a
défendu son pion mais qu'est-ce qu'il
veut jouer le joueur c'est quoi son
minuscule ci est envoyé le jour où son
nom mais il faut jouer bessin et mais
c'est surtout resserré on va juste avoir
un père pète
oui donc mais comment ont elles vu
oganian haïti ils disent que ce retour
c'est un ils avaient peur de dames f5
sur le tchat
mais bon oui oui oui ok ok ok merci
merci merci les mecs aux yeux quand même
mais bon ils ont ils auraient pu prendre
et jouer tour c'est ça notre nom à tous
bon ok il a au moins je comprends un
hoquet intéressant merci dame c'est une
situation parfaite qui vit mme quand les
spectateurs peuvent me corriger lorsque
voir y avait tout à fait intéressante
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui va nous arriver
maintenant ok tient à maintenant sur
tours signature f8 parce que la dame
menace plus g7 ou damev croisière par la
laddh à manger si c était bien placé
c'était très chaud pourrait regretter
qu'il n'a pas répété les coûts avaient
appris en prenant l'a39 aller maxime bon
signal mais si j'arrive à ça nous
redonne énormément de courage belle
époque si tu veux ça était normal pour
mac de gagner doter le parti
rien que moi je peux me rappeler de 2
millions de particules à gagner de cette
manière parce que la grille tchouk en
train d'être mal autant d'avocats 3,6
des machins c'est pas mal ça c'est quoi
ça qui peut être une fois nul comme hui
à 6 turbo 6 e tour 7-6 trop dangereux
mais est-ce que c'était moi quand même
au lieu de tour dames 6 dans macadam au
qatar ou assise dans ma chambre plutôt
versement ok puis importe ça va déranger
5 3 et 4 oui mais quand même
ok ça me tuerait est important après
tout c'est quoi ça ok tu mets là tout
sur harnes est toujours aux efforts de
peut proposer mon hockey et les mains tu
répondes nerveux au cayrol hockey nul
heureusement heureusement pour maxime
vlad parce qu'on est passé pas loin de
plus cinq mais oui mais oui c'est bon
allez il faut le défoncer en 960
maintenant ok comme en fait foi la
charge et âme à discuter ensemble et moi
guichetier ou cambridge et préparation
pour les échecs 950 me ok je les témoins
des jours spéciaux ils se préparent pour
ces trois partis qu'à la maison il m'a
dit qu il se prépare un peu quand même
mais juste réparé comment tu fais
tourner leur dis tu fais quoi pour se
préparer à ça au moins tu regardes cette
position de moines qui ont fait tourner
leur dis bien sûr mer
go tube vient pas innocent pour une
telle partie parce que peut-être tu vas
pas te débrouiller toi même donc si tu
veux les choux clos fouet un voyage
l'offreur et les deux loups savent donc
c'est une position que je suppose nous
tous on le voit pour la première fois
sauf quelques-uns mais nos deux
protagonistes mon mail et blanc peuvent
plus faire petit rapace ils ont bougé la
tour alors que les noirs peuvent encore
faire petit rock
merci pour m'expliquer parce que j'ai
jamais vraiment appris les règles du jeu
de ce joueur enfin tu peux si tu enlèves
le foie fuite et la dame des 8 mai
tombant g8 et la tournée fise est une
chose je comprends que lorsque tu viens
de dire maintenant une structure
ressemble un peu aux avants locaux sacré
semblait un peu aux structures d de la
can you may 5 bien sûr c'est une
tentative de simplifier le truc tout de
suite si je comprends bien des oeufs 6-2
dans des interdits en france sans se
salir
c'est pour ça que je joue cavalier seul
avec les dés que le cinq de devant et
autour de l'infocentre cote 1 go pour
nous libérer se disait grant
voilà tu vois juste moi par exemple je
savais même pas et ce kiosque où existe
la met juste et paisible comme vous ok
maintenant six tours de 8 faut deux
tours 8
m6 et le noir égalise ok ce coup-là tour
8 alors que devient pas une seule
possible le terme aux tirs au but pareil
de complètement sécurisé faire plus oui
mais comment qu'ai je ne pense pas que
c'est possible
ok maintenant soif wave 4 soit 4,6 à
l'heure est ok ok comme quoi une partie
de moins parce que ça promet de se
griser quand je vais tenter de mettre
les caméras vlad
après cette partie combien de mots de
braye combien le cadeau pour le bric
deux trois minutes
il faut un break très rapide ok je vais
bosser pietrus je pensais plus vite
rires au minimum mais c'est possible que
ça fasse tout sauter en essayant de m ok
il faut pas mais normalement ça doit
marcher
d'un autre côté
kiev c'est toi que l'expérience font que
tu t'en fous de six mois j'aurais fais 6
en mai ok et 6 les 17 et comme quoi les
besoins faut un coup fo 3 les noirs on a
pu en isolé qui serait un bien sûr et
quand même l'aïe comme quoi il veut lui
donner même pas ça ok peut-être grand
roque du coup pour les blancs foule cinq
fausses briques et éventuellement un peu
regardez nous louons peut offrir pas mal
de cours moi ça va être nul comme moi je
dont 80% pour que ce sont vos lieux bon
parce que c'est symétrique est la presse
plus pièces sur l'échiquier et le niveau
de deux joueurs et plus ou moins
équilibrés
c'est ce que disait grand roque priest
rice prisé tour d2